en direct de montréal bonjour à la
planète
ici l'équipe de tam-tam canada réunis
pour le plaisir de tous et chacun
nous allons aujourd'hui bien sûr parler
du thème mondial que sont les jeux
olympiques mais vu du canada nous allons
ajouter le point de vue canada pays est
très très puissant à ces jeux olympiques
autour de la table nous allons commencer
par celle qui sera une de nos
spécialistes aujourd'hui au niveau du
contenu on des 10 pc du contenant la au
moins une spécialiste ici du contenu
s'agit de oui oui bonjour oui alors oui
et les dut de la section chinoise de
radio canada international nous avons
bien sûr la bonne vieille équipe
technique qui appuient cette diffusion
en direct sur facebook live en direct de
montréal dont 15h11
il ya marie claude simard bonjour et il
ya les eaux gimeno toujours bonjour
monsieur
alors je pense que j'ai pas besoin de
jouer à la devinette te retrouves avec
vous vous connaissez donc le sujet de
l'émission aujourd'hui rien doute les
quatre tout il y en a qui reviennent à
tous les deux ans mes sources et leurs
problèmes alors écoutez gentiment il ya
quand même une sous définition à notre
thème démission aujourd'hui parce qu'on
les jeux olympiques ce très large
on parle bien sûr des jeux olympiques
d'hiver donc on rétrécit le champ de
notre intérêt mais il ya un aspect
précis nous allons discuter tous
ensemble aujourd'hui je sais que j'en ai
parlé un peu à tous mais vous savez vous
avais aucune idée de varrault où l'on se
dirige en ce moment un peu comme une
équipe de bobsleigh comme ceux qui
descendent la pente alors vous faire
jouer cette vidéo c'est notre deviner de
quoi on parle on vous montre des images
vous devinez le thème le sous thème de
cette émission sur les zones ep
qu'aujourd'hui vous décrivez évidemment
ce que vous voyez le réservoir les
serveurs donc les étudiants des
olympiques l'image des olympiques
là c'est le climat la vitesse mort dieu
oui
super on parle de monsieur parent nous
envoyer la wii l'haltérophilie mais
c'est pas en hiver ça non mais il ya là
dedans il ya de la ville à ces messieurs
gamme ont bondi et ça ça devienne ça
devrait ça se précise le thème se
précise je regardais un point avec
d'électricité qui passe à travers
je n'avais pas deviné non non pas encore
ben j'aurais fait vidéo je vous donne le
thème vous allez tout de suite
comprendre à la fois ci il est question
de du canada comme super puissance
[Musique]
beaucoup de données comme comble en 32
37 millions si on est toujours 2e et 3e
dans les jours d'hiver
c'est vraiment un très bon rapport
quantité des gens puis professionnels du
sport c'est vrai que l'expression non
oui nordiques alors été justement sur le
terrain de la première question
aujourd'hui on revient à plein en pleine
caméra plein studio ici pour la première
question remet vous les ménages cette
semaine je vous rappelle il ya trois ou
quatre questions par émission du foie il
y en a 3 des foyers en a quatre
aujourd'hui je pense que notre 5
je vous pose une question vous gagnez
des dépôts poète pourcentage à chacune
des questions
en espérant vous aurez 100 % à la fin
d'examen mais ça ne s'est jamais produit
90% c'est anne-marie niveau est avec
nous alors aussi la question le canada
sur une super puissance olympique mais
en quelle position s'attend à ce que le
canada se hisse à ces jeux en corée du
sud cette année mais troisième place
pour le nombre de médailles pour le
nombre de bataille c'est toujours le
nombre de médailles d'or en général qui
mais moi je dirais première place
revient ici de deuxième donc on a
vraiment un choix ici on est vingt ans
aucune d'entre vous n'avez la bonnerie
on a déjà eu la troisième place c'était
aux jeux de vancouver 2010 lorsqu'on
était bien sûr quand on est le pays hôte
en général en suisse dans les shows
comme astruc qui se passe et les juges y
trafiquent donc 2010 on était 3e mais en
général on arrive quatrième ou cinquième
en sept ans cette année ce qu'on soit
quatrième au niveau des médailles mais
il se pourrait qu'on répète l'exploit du
plus grand nombre de médailles d'or
c'est nous qui avons le record mondial
du plus nombre de médailles d'or et de
record fin de deux médailles aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver c'était en 2006
justement
mais ce sont les américains qui ont le
record absolu de toutes les médailles
généralement à segi sava personnes à
bonne réponse alors j'étais le plus
proche
vous étiez plus pas choisi troisième la
patrie de consolation malheureusement
oui
parlez-nous de c2c de ces
superpuissances ya pas que le canada il
ya beaucoup de puissance en jeu là c'est
pas juste une affaire de sport oui pour
les pays asiatiques la chine peut-être
oui c'est très fort c'est à dire que
c'est pas seulement le sport quand sept
il s'agit des jeux olympiques c'est très
politique
la performance des athlètes c'est lié
directement avec l'honneur du pays bas
vous allez me dire qu au canada c'est la
même chose mais sauf que en chine c'est
très commun que les meilleurs athlètes
se trouve à la fin après la retraite
dans le gouvernement
avoir un poste où ses auteurs mais oui
des fois c'est au les meilleurs ils vont
ils vont être quasiment être invités ou
bien encourager de faire partie du parti
communiste puis il pourrait être même le
ministre le ministre van de sport et
dans le domaine aux états unis les plus
proches en sport devienne président des
états unis 6
mais il ya aussi le pire exemple vous
savez qu'à l'époque de saddam saddam
hussein en irak eu tant le bâtiment de
leur comité de jeux olympiques il ya une
chambre de torture pour les actuels
c'est pour dire que commencer important
pour eux autres et puis ces politiques
et puis c'est aussi assez symbolique
comme cette fois on a vu que la corée du
sud a fait beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts
pour embarquer la corée du nord
ils ont même avoir une équipe
maintenance et je pense qu'on n'a jamais
vu ça des deux pays à faire une équipe
d'enquêté ministre canadien c'est un
cauchemar mais c'est cpo c'est touchant
pour les chinois quand on a vu que les
deux jeunes filles qui montent ce matin
montée pour eux aussi ce soit monté
l'escalier ensemble pour vers le oui
pour vers le flambeau olympique
parce que en chine aussi on a des
séparations de 40 ans et puis après
retrouvailles et tout ça et on voit
qu'on peut servir de dysport pour ce
genre de but
objectif une science et culturelles et
puis c'est très disons que c'est très
important pour la phase où l'honneur du
pays
alors nos spécialistes du contenant ici
que nous sommes nous trois jeunes ont
une tournée vers une autre species du
contenu qui est tous sur skype en ce
moment qui est pas tellement loin d'ici
pas loin du sang ben c'est quand même
assez loin de montréal vous êtes à
sherbrooke paname carignan bon c'est
vrai que c'est à peu près 100 125 et au
sud est de montréal
j ai travaillé un moment donné quand
j'étais un cancre on va vous dire qui
vous êtes parce que on joue pas au jeu
de la devinette
vous êtes vraiment une spécialiste de la
couverture journalistique des jeux
olympiques world cup vous en faites
votre domaine d'étude le domaine des
communications
vous êtes professeur co responsable des
programmes de deuxième cycle en
communication au département des lettres
et communications diversité de
sherbrooke
on vous a invité parce que nous ici au
canada on y family avec notre couverture
médiatique des autres jeux olympiques ça
tourne autour des médailles
donner l'exemple de jeunes parlent que
de médailles deux superpuissances
l'ip est relatif aux dieux superlatifs
mais c'est la même chose mais avec des
grandes nuances ailleurs dans le monde
est ce qu'il ya des couvertures qui sont
meilleurs que d'autres parce qu'on est à
l'époque des faits internati vous savez
comment c'est un oui on n avait pas
internet
d'ailleurs cette news est tellement de
l'année l'an dernier selon les
dictionnaires
on est vraiment été pas comment ces
questions sur la véracité des faits mais
en fait partout dans le monde
phénomène auquel on réfléchit beaucoup
on l'a vu d'ailleurs entre autres les en
2012 des journaux américains avaient cru
la question c'est l'objectivité de la
couverture des jeux olympiques
donc moi je m'intéresse beaucoup aux
questions éthiques et déontologiques des
médias quand on pense à la couverture
journalistique des jeux olympiques
un des éléments qu'elles ont des portes
s intéressait c est ce que on tombe bien
les jeux parce que quand on se rend
compte que c'est la même chose partout
dans le monde
à ce moment là les études du site est
beaucoup la france l'italie la
grande-bretagne comme peut-être les
pires joueurs dans le domaine ca du
concours soit de façon très chauvine
liste on est axée sur le pays
mais on n'a pas une couverture
représentatif de qu'est ce qui se passe
dans l'ensemble des jeux donc les
performances globales mondiales
on semble vraiment sur ce qui se passe
dans notre pays et le ça soulève quand
même coup questionnement là en matière
d'études journalistique à savoir est ce
que l'on devrait être plus objectif
quand on coupe les jeux ou est ce que
c'est normal que les journalistes
deviennent un peu aussi des partisans
qui veulent encourager leurs pays et
leurs habiletés qui deviennent souvent
très proches des athlètes du pays
ailleurs que la france soit un chauffe
pas mais que bbc par exemple se prêtent
au jeu d'une mauvaise couverture des
jeux olympiques ça me surprendrait je
vous dis ça d'instinct parce que moi je
travaille à l'autre cible ici ou à du
canada et jeu on est des organismes
cousin alors je suis un peu étonné
d'entendre que les britanniques des
britanniques est mentionné dans l'étude
en question
mais même chez nous radio canada ont
fait un très bon travail a pas deux mais
quand même une certaine pression pour
penser qu acheter la couverture des jeux
olympiques c'est une fortune pour les
télédiffuseurs qui ont les droits du
pendant l'année et
ce prix d'achat engendre certaines
conséquences cadeau qu'on veut
rentabiliser l'investissement
donc c'est normal qu par exemple la
couverture qui va être fait des jeux
soit très importante parce qu'il faut
rentabiliser cet investissement là donc
ça fait des émissions à la télé sur les
plates formes web à la radio mais ça
engendre aussi un espèce de phénomènes
où tout le monde sain qui doit
s'intéresser au jeu même si de prime
abord il est peut-être moins intéressés
par l'actualité sportive et donc ça
écrire l'engouement qui est un peu
poussé par le fait que l'investissement
doit être rentabilisé
et là on questionne est-ce que parfois
on donne trop de place dans la
couverture journalistique de jeu pour
rentabiliser cet investissement est ce
que les je mériterai toujours et les
unes ou telle nouvelle
est ce ça peut être questionnable et
puis cette structure là qui fait que par
exemple ce soit les red hot étudiants de
droit qui a obtenu le droit des jeux des
changes la couverture chez des
concurrents qui n'ont pas accès aux
mêmes contenus
et là qui doivent parfois ses intérêts
et couverture un peu plus alternatifs
par exemple souvent ils vont prendre des
stratégies comme faire des couvertures
un peu plus qu'on va appeler human donc
centré sur les athlètes sur leurs
familles parce qu'ils peuvent pour
recouvrir les jo en direct influence
beaucoup la couverture journalistique
structure financière avec jeu là j'ai
une question pour vous madame carignan
ont pu s'attendre quand même que la
population canadienne qui aime bien
regarder des jeux olympiques d'hiver
devrait en savoir surtout sur ses
athlètes alors c'est un peu normal non
que la société d'état ou tout autre
média leur présente en primeur parce que
ce que les performances des athlètes
canadiens qui ne pensait pas
oui oui c'est normal cc c'est là où ils
cassent tellement c'est normal que les
gens s'intéressent surtout à ce qui les
concerne un peu comme le rac et on va
peut-être faire la une des nouvelles si
le canadien de montréal aux acquis au
québec par exemple paillardes allemand
mais il gagne mais je le gagne la coupe
stanley mais on le fera pas si c'est une
équipe américaine par exemple pour ce
que la québécoise et c'est normal mais
on se demande quand même à quel point il
faut ouvrir sur le monde et donc les
gens aussi vont s'intéresser à des
sports qui connaissent peut-être moins
pendant les jeux olympiques
et ça aussi c'est un peu difficile parce
que les journalistes peuvent precia
liste de toutes les sports donc ça
pousse parfois ses intérêts
un peu plus à l'athlète que la
performance sportive comme il
oui vous avez une question mais je me
demande et aussi comme mike l'odyssée
c'est le besoin les besoins des
spectateurs des gens des canadiens
ordinaires qui sait comme c'est normal
de vouloir regarder les son propre pays
les la performance des athlètes de son
propre pays
je pense qu'il ya un équilibre dedans
parce que je suis d'accord c'est la
responsabilité des journalistes qui
présente le monde présente d'autres
d'autres pays
il ya un équilibre assez difficile à
maintenir la pression
il faut éclairer difficile à maintenir
et le parfois je pense qu'on le perd à
certains membres pour se concentrer
vraiment sur les athlètes même lorsque
des contre performances en a beaucoup de
mal à aller parler négativement de nos
athlètes parce qu'on peut vraiment les
encourager et ce parfois mais ça soulève
des critiques
il ya quelques années par exemple pierre
foglia dans une autre vie et de faire
soulignait justement qui ont donné pour
objectif avec nos propres et parfois
même on leur donne tellement de place
qu'on parlait davantage eu que de leur
performance qui voulait aussi faire la
fête et comment dida qui veulent se
faire voir la lige donc qu'ils veulent
qu'on parle plus des athlètes parfois de
leur performance
si vous aviez l'occasion de se retrouver
avec un petit groupe de travail parmi
dont des gens des médias
deux ans avant la tenue de jeux
olympiques par exemple les prochains
jeux olympiques j'ai aucune idée où
est-ce que ça va se dérouler problème au
canada c'est sûr mais est ce que est ce
que vous critiquez qu'il vous à les
réunir autour de la table pour augmenter
la qualité d'une couverture si c'était à
vous de décider qui table et de quoi on
parle
mais ce qu'il faudrait tester d'abord
c'est quelle importance on doit accorder
aux jeux olympiques pendant la
couverture donc s'assurer qu'ils on
conserve un regard sur ce qui se passe
dans l'actuelle des propos que par
exemple des organisations puissent
profiter d'un espèce d'eclyps médiatique
où l'on couvrira pas des nouvelles
d'importance parce que certains peuvent
profiter des jeux olympiques de la
concentration qui nous autour de cet
événement là pour passer d'autres
nouvelles
qui vont être ignorée puis que les
entreprises ont intérêt par exemple à
faire il n'y aurait donc s'assurer qu'on
regarde un regard sur tout ce qui se
passe dans l'actualité puis qu'on couvre
selon le degré d'importance alors
réfléchir à quel degré d aux sports est
ensuite bien faut doser avec l attention
on donne aux résultats des performances
sportives aux éléments les plus
importants de chacune des étapes chacune
des compétitions
et puis aux athlètes comme thème donc
trouver le bon degré latin c'est pas
toujours facile et est-ce qu'on a les
bons experts qui connaissent bien tous
les disciplines sportives parce que vont
couvrir larqué par exemple pour les
canadiens sont plus faciles que couvrir
le savent pas moins de discipline pour
qu'on aime ou parfois moins comme le
bobsleigh ou out où on peut couvrir
seulement là aux olympiques mais c'est
certain que ça soulève des
questionnements et un ex amant est ce
que on accorde trop d'importance aux
jeux olympiques est ce qu'ils ont perdu
un peu du sang ce qu'avait dans le
premier je voulais c'était vraiment un
très bel outil de paix très pacifique et
certains politiciens profité aussi pour
négocier donc méritait vraiment un
intérêt médiatique différent peut-être
d'aujourd'hui on peut se poser la
question chacun son interprétation n'est
pas de bonne ou mauvaise
je suis très navré de vous avoir parlé
aujourd'hui moi qui voulais faire les
quatre prochaines émissions sur les jeux
olympiques et le rôle central que le
canada y joue un jeu
je suis comblée dans l'actualité bref et
puis qu'il faut avoir un regard oui
canadien parce que les gens
s'attendaient mais tout en conservant ce
unsa mais bien parler veut pas dire ne
pas vous avez bien paru aujourd'hui
surtaxé puis merci d'avoir l'invitation
hier comme ça au pied levé
c'était fin vraiment sympathique de
votre part ça me fait plaisir
alors ça c'était madame marie-eve
carignan qui est docteur un docteur
maria callas le professeur responsable
département des lettres et communiqué
cité de sherbrooke
on voit ces sympathiques c'était
vraiment sympa elle ne peut pas nous
voir c'est le secret on voulait pas vous
dire avant parce que ça aurait gâché le
gâteau il aurait pu lever
mais peu à peu de voir mais on pouvait
l'avoir donc le plus important est
réussi et dire qu'on est responsable de
la diffusion des jeux olympiques ici au
canada nous radio canada quand même bon
je dois dire que nous avons choisi le
thème aujourd'hui à notre web programme
sans influence sans directives de la
direction sans aucun ne sont même pas de
diop stéphane je devrai maintenant 0
pourtant nous avons payé cher la
diffusion de ces jurys pourtant nous on
travaille à côté des sports
les mouvements qui a dansé jour là c'est
incroyable à cinq mètres des sports en
langage canadiens nous sommes à peu près
presque vingt pieds voilà écoutez c'est
pas fini on va continuer à parler de la
superpuissance canadienne aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver
j'y tiens quand même au moins une
émission là dessus voici on a deviné à
quoi correspond ce graphique c'est une
devinette s'est pas fait pas partie du 2
du jeu mais vous les méninges voici
deviner à quoi correspond ce graphique
là quand c'était la participation du
canada dans les jeux olympiques rapport
avec l'argent
je dirais les sommets des semis
investissements non non l'argent qu'ils
gagnent
non non publique non je vous dise
tout ce que vous dites pourrait
correspondre à ce graphique mais vous
n'êtes pas dans la zone
ok j'ai ajouté de la couleur est
ébranlée voilà des canadiens aux
olympiques d'hiver c'est à chaque année
voyez-vous pour batman un chaman
nous sommes vraiment une super puissance
moi je n'y a pas d'autres termes je ne
peux pas utiliser d'autres terres c'est
nous par rapport à nous et ça va
améliorer parce qu'il ya des russes qui
ont pas pu participer ou ne peuvent pas
participer
c'est à peu près là un petit nombre il y
en reste 169 m'ont dit que ça va
augmenter les chances pour le canada de
ici son nombre de médailles
voilà on va revenir sur la question des
médailles plus tard émission c'est
tellement un sujet profond et précieux
si vous permettez
on va aller vers notre question qu'on a
posés à nos internautes sur facebook
cette semaine et nous avons reçu 11 nous
faire sourire plusieurs voici la
question oui vous ne la lisent et qu'est
ce qui vous attire le plus ou qu'est ce
que vous aimez tant les jeux olympiques
d'hiver comme ceux de kyoto la plus
douce ou dit en langage n'aura du
canadien ce sera la question qu'est ce
qui vous attire
voici je demandais à marie-claude vous
l'avez déjà lu la réponse de cet
auditeur en afrique qui était giovanni
bengono ucama d'accord voilà alors moi
je vis au cameroun donc les jeux
olympiques d'hiver ne me concerne pas vu
la situation géographique du cameroun et
il neige même pas ici il ya un proverbe
qui dit la pole ne parle pas des
histoires de dans l'axé je lis des beaux
prés verts ben alors on les en ont
beaucoup comme cela j'ai fait un
reportage amené là dessus sur les
proverbes camerounais [ __ ] je parle est
un poète au cameroun qui est un
spécialiste de sa hotte être sortir un
jour se dire ah mais
y'en a des pays qui est déjà je ne
cherchais pas je les trouve pas quoi il
ya une des pays qui se présentait dans
le jeux olympiques d'hiver la cérémonie
puis il y avait un poil oui oui un poil
avec les bandes est il de son pays à
niveau c'est-à-dire à poil là parce
qu'attention là il avait un coup à un
poignet il y avait quelque chose à
moitié nue apporte 15 degrés c'est fait
c'est la cérémonie la lui il s'est
promené comme ça oui c'est la façon dont
ils repassent à son pays mais quand même
en chine où on dit quand je sais pas en
français ces quatre pays donc donc dans
l'océan pacifique que lille ii les îles
tonga
mais il ya au niveau des africains il ya
cinq ou sept pays nouveaux qui viennent
cette année s'ajouter en touche parce
qu'ils aident ils ont très hâte est
africaine pour tout le continent à ces
jeux total des deux des applets et 2965
je me suis ça de mémoire évidemment je
pense que mon temps à vérifier
statistiques quand je dors je voulais
vous demander justement aux sujets tels
que des athlètes
je suis sûr que personne n'a diffusé
cette information avant nous je suis sûr
parce que j'en ai fait ma question
deuxième portion de rue mais voulait
menem jeu de près combien d'athlètes du
canada participent à ces jeux qu'on
vient d'être là du canada participent à
ces jeux j'ai donné le total de 1965 ça
vous donne un repère donc ne me dites
pas 4000 les oh non non aux 4000 noms
mais jeudi
à peu près 3 ça vous dit pour cette
année oui pour cette année je crois que
ces deux sens je vais faire semblant
d'être pressé de 115 112 115 193 193
je dois vous avouer ce matin j'ai parlé
avec mon père m'a demandé à combien
d'athlètes canadiens qui participent et
stupidement juillet donner la réponse
j'espère qu'elle va oublier avant
l'émission 225 musée c'est pas eu la
bonne réponse était très proches très
bonne mémoire un avantage indéniable sur
les sur tout le monde ici on va vous
accorder le point mais je sais pas vous
êtes moins strict que des juges aux jeux
olympiques c'est bien sûr aucune note
presque parfaite 9 sur 10 on vous donne
un bon fonds de tiroirs 30% d'accor
alors c'est 00 30 pour ça et la
prochaine question ce sera peut-être 50
pour ça je voulais vous montrer
justement certains de ces athlètes
canadiens 200 m cinq athlètes canadiens
80 cet entraîneur c'est la plus
importante de toute l'histoire des jeux
olympiques
pour lui le monde est déçu les
américaines où bat avec 247
voilà ça c'est vraiment une équipe qui
fait beaucoup jaser on parle beaucoup
d'elle c'est l'équipe féminine ont
beaucoup d'espoir elle pourrait
remporter une cinquième médaille d'or
parce que new look qui ont des champions
vous le savez au niveau des jeux aussi
lille une vidéo ou avec les hommes
dessus monsieur moins intéressants et
eux aussi pourraient remporter jeu c'est
très excitant ce que je dis des fois
alors ça j'aimerais remporter deux
médailles
d'autant plus que les russes ne
participe pas à la fois voilà sont
russes nous allons maintenant être la
superpuissance alors ça c'est notre
équipe féminine
je pense qu'ils sont 25 ans tous
maintenant je voulais vous demandez pas
me perdre dans les feuilles nouveau de
la couverture on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
du rau de radio canada sauf le critiquer
abondamment des politiciens
mais sérieusement couvrir ces jeux ça
commence au moins deux ans avant la
tenue des jeux comme y en a à toutes les
deux une chance que ça prend pas plus de
tant sinon ça demanderait une équipe
extraordinaire niveau de la
planification est elle responsable à
radio-canada responsable de la
planification de ces jeux elle travaille
à tous tes deux ans et c'est un nouveau
défi qui relançait son nom c'est
catherine dupont et on l'a interviewé
tout juste avant son départ pour la
corée du sud voici ce qu'elle avait à
nous dire
les athlètes excellent et l'intérêt des
canadiens est vraiment là pour les jeux
d'hiver on est une des nations
effectivement une des plus médaillées
donc les jeux seront très suivis
d'ailleurs la statistique au canada 87 %
des gens ont été en contact avec du
contenu olympique durant sotchi que ce
soit à la télé ou sur le web y est pour
rien qu'ils bossent les jeux d'été
atteindre 91% à peu près de la
population canadienne mais donc on peut
pas baisser les bras et penser que les
jeux d'hiver c'est des petits jeux au
contraire c'est un grand déploiement
donc ça veut dire consomme au dos que
dès qu'on termine un jeu on prêt on
commence à préparer le suivant
bien sûr c'est une équipe de quelques
personnes on est peut-être trois ou
quatre tout débuts à imaginer quelle
sera notre couverture qu'elle sera
nos moyens notre déploiement et on
commence tout de suite les négociations
avec l'organisme olympiques qui
s'appelle obs olympique broadcasting
service par exemple le picard est
convaincu paix sur place ça doivent
décider presque 2 en avance pour ce qui
est de tous qui équipements sa part en
bateau la plupart du temps surtout quand
on a des jeux qui sont allés au bout de
la planète
donc on a eu des conteneurs quelques
conteneurs remplis
il faut rien oublier parce que c'est
beaucoup plus coûteux d'envoyer
l'équipement par avion alors on va le
payer cher si on oublie il faut être
vraiment très organisés et prêts et on
en voit donc les conteneurs par bateau
et dans ce cas ci ça a transité via
vancouver pour prendre le bateau vers la
corée autour du mois de octobre premier
conteneur et novembre le dernier sur
place donc ça s'est fait avant les fêtes
mais là plus pour être bien prêt et
quand on arrive dans une couverture que
aussi grandiose que les jeux olympiques
il ya tellement de gens qui mettent la
main à la pâte pour faire de ces de
cette couverture là quelque chose
d'exceptionnel pour les canadiens que
que c'est un plaisir que d'avoir à vivre
ça avec eux ils de voir et d'écouter
tout ce qui est produit en couverture
pour les jeux il est maintenant 11h38 du
port de montréal en direct et jeux
olympiques bien sûr sur notre plateforme
à radio-canada intentional voici un
petit test parce que je pense qu'on peut
introduire un nouvel élément de défi à
cette émission en direct je vous demande
une tâche celui le premier qui me fais
tu le plus rapidement gagne non voici
très simplement trouvé mois le nombre de
médailles déjà qu'on a accordé au canada
je pense qu'on y produit déjà sur la
liste parce que ça commençait déjà lewis
a déjà commencé malheureusement
aujourd'hui j'ai entendu ce matin à la
radio de radio canada qu'on avait gagné
quelque chose alors je vois ça qu'est-ce
qu'on a gagné
j'ai gagné une équipe mais est-ce qu'on
a des ges si je pense qu'on adore oui
oui oui le plus qu'à plus précieux et je
pense qu'on a atteint 29
29 28 médailles d'or pour le canada donc
on n'a pas gagné
avant il faut alors pendant qu'on
cherche à ce que les internautes sont
témoins de votre recherche
combinant ça me rend avec ajout aco a
besoin d'un cours de formation
sinon on t'écoute aussi madame alors
c'est ça pendant vous cherchez oui
question pour vous puis question pour
les eaux
dis-moi questions pour marie-claude
pendant que vous cherchez la quelle
ville canadienne aurait de bonnes
chances d'organiser des jeux olympiques
d'hiver 2026 est ce qu'on a fait la
demande
absolument on est en attendant il ya
déjà des pourparlers et des visites à
dakar le comité olympique dans cette
ville salaires la ville de québec
atterri à charléty t elle à retirer son
projet calgary calgary je pense que
rollin on a eu des discussions
est ce que c'est bon pour l'économie ce
que c'est mauvais et cédera 2000 2022 je
sais que c'était j'ai décidé pour pékin
c'est vrai mais oui 2022 s'est piqué est
en avance d'une nouvelle moi j'étais pas
au courant que parler de vingt six 26
jeux s'est passé c'est pas quelques
rites non c'est calgary merci thierry
alors j'ai une vidéo au sujet de calgary
à ce qu'on peut la présenter pendant
qu'on poursuit d'autres recherches
voici la vidéo il paraît que je vais
vous montrer c'est d'aider les images de
la tenue des jeux olympiques à calgary
en 1980 les gens sont trop jeunes ici
qu'en 1986 86 86
c'est ce à quoi l'a alors là c'est en
anglais évidemment si c'est des images
qu'on a tiré 88,88 pensez vous pas de
mémoire
oui mais 88 c'est le jeu c'est les jeux
tu étais non inscrit 88 mais cet
écriteau sur ces 80 vous avez raison
ouais bah oui cela me souvenir
me reviennent à la mémoire et voilà il
paraît qu'on avantage de calgary et le
comité s'est déplacé le cio s'est
déplacé et à une délégation c'était il
ya quelques jours à peine en disant ce
n'est qu'elle gary vous avez déjà des
installations elles sont encore en bonne
forme
enfin en bonne en bon état et on
pourrait réutiliser les mêmes sans coups
extraordinaires dont plusieurs villes se
retirent ne veulent pas présenter de
candidatures calgary dit finalement ces
jeux là voyez le cerveau dont 20000
places à l'intérieur qu'on pourrait
utiliser dans cette ville qui dont le
profil a beaucoup changé sur la ville
pétrolière économique de l'ouest du
canada
et voilà au milieu la petite photo de
stéphane en 1988 oui mieux j'étais je
devrais me souvenir de ces jeux pourtant
j'y ai participé comme beaucoup d'autres
blague à part ce serait pour la dernière
question y'a pas mais je cherche je mets
l'espagnol ménagers l'olimpico celle où
on voit la quantité médaille pays à
google y apparaît pas encore pourquoi
vous cherchez pas à radio canada mais
vous parlez de 88 et ça m'a étonné parce
que j'étais en toge et faire la
recherche à 1904 87
les agents secrets de la corée du nord a
fait exploser ont fait exploser un avion
du code de la corée du sud pour sa
beauté
juste avant les jeux olympiques d'été de
l'année suivante c'est à dire 80 8
hockey mike hayes et qui est passible
depuis les jeux olympiques la même année
ainsi que là je pense conception on
soulignera qu on faisait encore c'est à
tous les quatre ans les jeux olympiques
d'hiver et de jeux olympiques d'été ouï
je montrais mais il ya ces dossiers le
solo ports partout ya pas d accord sont
tartas sur les effets de match où
beaucoup de confusion autour de cette
table
franchement j'suis d'eau douce en
officiel on vous croit mais il ya eu
victoire ça c'est une jante enthousiasme
et c'est peut-être y en a des
compétitions plus long alors il commence
avant même les jours de trois jours
avant on les jours des délais grain
oh bien sûr mais l'histoire c'est que
c'est pour des qualifications c'est pas
des médailles encore c'est vraiment pour
rentrer dans le jeu alors il ya eu
confusion au niveau de la date de 1988
1987 1989 au niveau juste des pics
d'hiver de calgary il y en aura pas au
niveau des jeux olympiques d'hiver de
vancouver
vous allez tout savoir la bonne réponse
parce que c'est encore assez frais à la
mémoire c'est en 2010 je gagnais pas de
point de pourcentage pour ça mais voici
la dernière question remuez vous les
ménages je vous rappelle qu'elle à 30%
et vous n'avez pas voulu m'accorder 10%
pour la première
la réponse était 4 puis moi j'étais plus
proche moi je puis de problème avec ça
une victoire se dessine gepeep à l'amex
voici la dernière question à combien
s'élève aujourd'hui le déficit de la
ville de vancouver qui a été l'hôte des
jeux olympiques d'hiver de 2010 ce temps
combien ce que ça il ya un manque à
gagner
combien c'est difficile était fait 200
millions 200 millions suis de montréal
étaient autour d'un milliard donc
s'influencent un petit peu votre
pro memoria long des spéciales les jeux
de montréal de 2002 1976 qui étaient des
jeux d'hiver bien sûr j'ai été bon il va
toutes les stars digital avec sa 500
milles déficit de 500 millions ok je le
reconnais que j'ai aucune idée
ok demi quand même une réponse ou
pourriez peut-être avoir non plus je
vais je vais plutôt à 150 millions ils
sont 50 millions alors la question était
à combien s'élève aujourd'hui le déficit
de la ville de vancouver aux deux jets
jeux olympiques d'hiver de 2010 et
s'élève à 0 0 a mis un jeu de comptables
non je n'en ai pas qu'ils proche la
bonne réponse mais qui a la bonne
référence veut surtout quand il s'agit
des chiffres
oui bon on fait bravo à vancouver bravo
à jouer et on va terminer sur ces images
on va fermer notre émission facebook
live avec ces images qui vont entre nous
c'est un langage de signes pour vraiment
les nouveaux vêtements de nous à tête
encore et encore une fois cette année
c'est la compagnie de la baie de
l'hudson qui a été qui c'est une blague
rifle rien ça représentait donc toujours
des enfants parce que c'était à ottawa
en compagnie du premier ministre
justin trudeau toujours très bien
habillé lui-même rappel je sais pas si
c'était pour les manques ou var
mais il y avait plus y'a ténu qui
étaient confectionnés en chine ses fils
était commun ok on qu'est ce qu'on fait
on bénéfices plutôt la chine qu'elle
nous sommes nous mêmes en faisant les
choses c'est olympic les erreurs de
jugement ou chance quand je n'ai plus eu
ce qui est important en important c'est
de gagner des médailles
écoutez et merci beaucoup pour cette
première émission de 4 sur les jeux
olympiques d'hiver du canada en corée du
sud de ce fut un plaisir avec une de nos
spécialistes du contenu félicitations à
mon goût vous êtes sérieux vous allez
faire 4 et oui et puis parce que c'est
ce côté là c'est sa caméra la semaine
prochaine merci